here with more editor-in-chief just the
news.com john solomon john tell us about
your report
yeah listen there's a scene unfolding
saturday and sunday while the spinsters
at the pentagon the state department in
the white house are saying any american
who wants to come home is going to be
able to come home meanwhile there are
americans waving their passports they
got through the taliban checkpoints
they're at the gate that the u.s
military controls they're waving their
passports we are americans let us in and
they were turned away uh and a colonel
who is witnessing this from afar in a
command center says we're bleeping
leaving american citizens behind it he
could not believe it i've talked to
soldiers that have talked to the friends
of the front lines the soldiers wanted
to turn the key on that gate and let
americans in the state department and
their command chain would not allow them
in and everything that was going on
there debunked what the biden
administration was telling the american
people on television so the military has
to take orders from the
commander-in-chief we already had one
guy that got in trouble for speaking out
about this failure uh we have
retired 90 plus admirals generals
find this whole thing abhorrent they've
spoken out
nobody's being held accountable joe's
patting himself and everybody else on
the back
but we're now in a situation you tell me
if any of this is wrong we had americans
at karzai international airport at the
gate in contact with our military and
they didn't go to the gate and get them
on the planes that were mostly empty
that left the final planes that left
yes that is that is accurate from the
documents that's accurate from the
private citizens who ran the rescue
mission and it's accurate from the
accurate from the military officials who
confirm that is what happened at the
gate saturday and sunday
if i was in the military i would resign
i couldn't work for this guy
i couldn't i couldn't live with myself
having to leave americans behind
uh great reporting john solomon we
appreciate it thanks hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else